The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, so
this is an important day,
and Friday was an important day.
I hope you enjoyed Professor
Sra's terrific lecture as much
as I did.
You probably saw me taking notes
like mad for the section that's
now to be written about
stochastic gradient descent.
And he promised a
theorem, if you remember,
and there wasn't time.
And so he was going
to send it to me
or still is going
to send it to me.
I'll report, I
haven't got it yet,
but I'll bring it to class,
waiting to see, hopefully.
And that will give us a chance
to review stochastic gradient
descent, the central
algorithm of deep learning.
And then this today is
about the central structure
of deep neural nets.
And some of you will know
already how they're connected,
what the function F,
the learning function--
you could call it the
learning function--
that's constructed.
The whole system is aiming
at constructing this function
F which learns the
training data and then
applying it to the test data.
And the miracle is that it
does so well in practice.
That's what has transformed
deep learning into such
an important application.
Chapter 7 has been
up for months on the
math.mit.edu/learningfromdata
site,
and I'll add it to Stellar.
Of course, that's where
you'll be looking for it.
OK, and then the second,
the back propagation,
the way to compute
the gradient, I'll
probably reach that idea today.
And you'll see it's the chain
rule, but how is it organized.
OK, so what's the structure?
What's the plan for
deep neural nets?
Good.
Starting here, so what
we have is training data.
So we have vectors, x1 to x--
what should I use for
the number of samples
that we have in
the training data?
Well, let's say D for Data.
OK.
And each vector, those are
called feature vectors,
so equals feature vectors.
So each one, each x,
has like m features.
So maybe my notation
isn't so hot here.
I have a whole lot of vectors.
Let me not use the subscript
for those right away.
So vectors, feature
vectors, and each vector
has got maybe shall
we say m features?
Like, if we were measuring
height and age and weight
and so on, those
would be features.
The job of the neural
network is to create--
and we're going to classify.
Maybe we're going to classify
men and women or boys
and girls.
So let's make it a
classification problem,
just binary.
So the classification
problem is--
what shall we say?
Minus 1 or 1, or 0
or 1, or boy or girl,
or cat or dog, or truck or car,
or anyway, just two classes.
So I'm just going to do
two-class classification.
We know which class the
training data is in.
For each vector x, we
know the right answer.
So we want to create a function
that gives the right answer,
and then we'll use that
function on other data.
So let me write that down.
Create a function F
of x so that gets--
most of gets the class correct.
In other words, F of x
should be negative for when
the classification is
minus 1, and F of x
should be positive when the
classification is plus 1.
And as we know, we
don't necessarily
have to get every x,
every sample, right.
That may be over-fitting.
If there's some sample that's
just truly weird, by getting
that right we're
going to be looking
for a truly weird
data in the test set,
and that's not a good idea.
We're trying to
discover the rule that
covers almost all cases but
not every crazy, weird case.
OK?
So that's our job,
to create a function
F of x that is correct on
almost all of the training data.
Yeah.
So before I draw the
picture of the network,
let me just remember to
mention the site Playground.
I don't know if you've looked at
that, so I'm going to ask you,
playground@tensorflow.org.
How many of you know that
site or have met with it?
Just a few, OK.
OK, so it's not a very
sophisticated site.
It's got only four
examples, four examples.
So one example is a whole
lot of points that are blue,
B for Blue, inside
a bunch of points
that are another set that are
O for Orange, orange, blue.
OK, so those are the two
classes, orange and blue.
So the points x and the feature
vector here is just the xy,
the coordinates features are the
xy coordinates of the points.
And our job is to
find a function that's
positive on these points and
negative on those points.
So there is a simple model
problem, and I recommend--
well, just partly--
if you're a expert
in deep learning.
This is for children, but
morally here, I certainly
learned from playing
in this playground.
So you set the step size.
Do you set it, or
does it set it?
I guess you can change it.
I don't think I've changed it.
What else do you set?
Oh, you set the nonlinear
activation, the nonlinear
activation function,
active I'll say function.
And let me just go over here
and say what function people now
mostly use.
The activation
function is called
ReLU pronounced different ways.
I don't know how we got
into that crazy thing.
For this function,
that is 0 and x.
So the function,
ReLU is a function
of x is the maximum
the larger of 0 and x.
The point is, it's not
linear, and the point
is that if we didn't allow
nonlinearity in here somewhere,
we couldn't even solve
this playground problem.
Because if our classifiers
were all linear classifiers,
like support vector machines,
I couldn't separate the blue
from the orange with a plane.
It's got to somehow create some
nonlinear function which maybe
the function is trying to be--
a good function would be a
function of r and theta maybe,
maybe r minus 5.
So maybe the
distance out to that.
Let's suppose that
distance is 5.
Then, r minus 5 will be
negative on the blues,
because r is small.
And r minus 5 will be
positive on the oranges,
because r is bigger.
And therefore, we will have
the right signs, less than 0
or greater than 0,
and it'll classify
this data, this training data.
Yeah.
So it has to do that.
This is not a hard one to do.
There are four examples,
as I say, two are trivial.
It finds a good function.
Well yeah, I've forgotten,
they're so trivial,
they shouldn't be mentioned, and
then this is the medium test.
And then the hard
test is when you
have a sort of
spiral of oranges,
and inside, you have
a spiral of blues.
That was cooked up by a fiend.
So the system is trying
to find a function
that's positive on one spiral
and negative on the other
spiral, and that takes quite a
bit of time, many, many epochs.
I learned what an epoch is.
Did you know what an epoch is?
I didn't know
whether it was just
a fancy word for counting the
steps in gradient descent.
But it counts the
steps, all right,
but one epoch is the number
of steps that matches
the size of the training data.
So if you have a
million samples--
where ordinary gradient descent
you would be doing a million--
you'd have a million by a
million problem per step.
Of course, stochastic
gradient descent
just does a mini-batch of 1 or
32 or something, but anyway.
So you have to do it
enough mini-batches
so that the total
number you've covered
is the equivalent of one full
run through the training data,
and that was an
interesting point.
Did you pick up that point?
That in stochastic
gradient descent,
you could either
do a mini-batch,
and then put them back in the
soup, so with replacement.
Or you could just put
your data in some order,
from one to a zillion.
So here's a first x
and then more and more
x's, and then just
randomize the order.
So you'd have to randomize the
order for stochastic gradient
descent to be
reasonable, and then
take a mini-batch
and a mini-batch
and a mini-batch.
And when you get to the bottom,
you've finished one epoch.
And then you'd probably
randomize again, maybe,
if you wanted to live right.
And go through the
mini-batches again,
and probably do
1,000 times or more.
Anyway, so I haven't said yet
what you do, what this F of x
is like, but you can sort
of see it on the screen.
Because as it creates
this function F,
it kind of plots it.
And what you see on the screen
is the 0 set for that function.
So perfect would be for
it to go through 0--
if I had another color.
Oh, I do have another color.
Look, this is the first time the
whole semester blue is up here.
OK, so if the function
was positive there--
in this part, on the blues--
and negative outside that
region for the oranges, that
would be just what we want.
Right?
That would be what this little
Playground site is creating.
And on the screen,
you'll see it.
You'll see this curve,
where it crosses 0.
So that curve,
where it crosses 0,
is supposed to
separate the two sets.
One set is positive,
one set is negative,
where 0 is in between.
And the point is, it's not a
straight line, because we've
got this nonlinear function.
This is nonlinear, and
it allows us to have
functions like r minus 5.
And so at 5, that's where
the function would be 0,
and you'll see
that on the screen.
You might just go to
playground@tensorflow.
Of course, TensorFlow
is a big system.
This is the child's
department, but I
thought it was pretty good.
And then on this
site, you decide
how many layers there will be,
how many neurons in each layer.
So you create the structure
that I'm about to draw.
And you won't be able to
get to solve this problem
to find a function F
that learns that data
without a number of layers
and a number of neurons.
If you don't give it enough,
you'll see it struggling.
The 0 set tries to follow this,
but it gives up at some point.
This one doesn't
take too many layers,
and the two trivial examples,
just a few neurons do the job.
OK.
So now, that's a little
commented on one website.
If you know other websites
that I should know
and should call attention to,
could you send me an email?
I'm just not aware of
everything that's out there.
Or if you know a good
Convolutional Neural Net, CNN,
that is available
to practice on,
where you could give
it the training set.
That's what I'm
talking about here.
I'd be glad to
know, because I just
don't know all that I should.
OK.
So what does the
function look like?
Well, as I say, linear
isn't going to do it,
but linear is a very important
part of it, of this function
F. So the function F
really has the form--
well, so we start here
with a vector of one,
two, three, four, m is five.
This is the vector
x, five components.
OK, so let me erase that now.
OK, so then we have layer 1
with some number of points.
Let's say, n1 is 6 neurons,
and let me make this simple.
I'll just have that one layer,
and then I'll have the output.
This will be the output
layer, and it's just
going to be one number.
So I'm going to have a matrix,
A1, that takes me from this.
A1 will be 6 by 5, because I
want 6 outputs and 5 inputs.
6 by 5 matrix, so I have
30 weights to choose there.
And so the y that
comes out is going
to be y1 will be A1 times x0.
So x0 is the feature
vector with 5 components.
So that's a purely
linear thing, but we also
want an offset
function, offset vector.
So that's a vector.
Then, this, the y that's
coming out, has 6 components.
The A1 is 6 by 5,
the x0 was 5 by 1,
and then of course,
this is 6 by 1.
So these are the weights.
Yeah, I'll call them all
weights, weights to compute.
So these are connected.
The usual picture is to
show all these connections.
I'll just put in some of them.
So in here, we have 30 plus
6 parameters, 36 parameters,
and then I'm going
to close this.
It's going to be a very shallow
thing, so that will be just 1
by 6.
Yeah.
OK.
Right, so we're just
getting one output.
So that's just a vector at this
final point, but of course,
that the whole idea
of deep neural nets
is that you have many layers.
So 36 more realistically is
in the tens of thousands,
and you have it multiple times.
And the idea seems to be
that you can separate what
layer one learns about the data
and from what layer two learns
about the data.
Layer one-- this A1, apparently
by just looking after
the computation--
this learns some basic
facts about the data.
The next, A2 which would go in
here, would learn more detail,
and then A3 would
learn more details.
So we would have a
number of layers,
and it's that construction that
has made neural net successful.
But I haven't finished, because
right now, it's only linear.
Right now, I just have,
I'll call it A2 in here.
Right now, I would just
have a matrix multiplication
apply A1 and then apply A2,
but in between there is a 1
by 1 action on each
by this function.
So that function
acts on that number
to give that number
back again or to give 0.
So in there is ReLU.
In this comes ReLU on each,
6 copies of ReLU acting
on each of those 6 numbers.
Right?
So really x1 comes from
y1 by applying ReLU to it.
Then, that gives the x.
So here are the y's
from the linear part,
and here are the x--
that's y1.
That's a vector y1 from just
the linear plus an affine map.
Linear plus constant,
that's affine.
And then the next step
is component by component
we apply this function, and
we get x1, and then do it
again and again and again.
So do you see the function?
How do I describe now
the function F of x?
So the learning function
which depends on the weights,
on the A's and b's.
So I start with an
x, I apply A1 to it.
Yeah, let me do this.
This is the function F of x.
F of x is going to
be F3, let's say,
of F2 of F1 of x, one, two,
three, parentheses, right?
OK, so it's a chain,
you could say.
F is a-- what's the right
word for a chain of functions,
if I take a function
of a function?
The reason I use the word
chain is that the chain rule
gives the derivative.
So a function of a function
of a function, that's
called composition,
composing function.
So this is a composition.
I don't know if there's a
standard symbol for starting
with F1 and do some composition
and do some composition.
And now what are
those separate F's?
So the separate F's are the--
F1 of a vector would
be-- it includes
the ReLU part, the nonlinear
part, of A1, x0 plus b1.
So two parts, you do
the linear or affine map
on your feature vector,
and then component
by component you apply
that nonlinear function.
And it took some years before
that nonlinear function
became a big favorite.
People imagined
that it was better,
it was important, to
have a smooth function.
So the original functions
were sigmoids, like S curves,
but of course, it turned
out that experiments showed
that this worked even better.
Yeah, so that would
be F1, and then F2
would have the same form, and
F3 would have the same form.
So maybe this had 36
weights, and the next one
would have another number
and the next another number.
You get quite complicated
functions by composition,
by like e to the sine of x, or
e to the sign of the logarithm
of x, or things like that.
Pure math has asked, what
functions can you get?
Try to think of them all.
Now, what kind of
functions do we have here?
What can I say about F of x as
a function, as a math person?
What kind of a function is it?
So it's created out of
matrices and vectors,
out of a linear or affine
map, followed by a nonlinear,
by that particular
nonlinear function.
So what kind of
a function is it?
Well, I've written those
words down up here, and F of x
is going to be a continuous
piecewise linear function.
Because every step
is continuous,
that's a continuous function.
Linear functions are a
continuous functions,
so we're taking a composition
of continuous function,
so it's continuous.
And it's piecewise linear,
because part of it is linear,
and part of it is
piecewise linear.
So this is some continuous,
piecewise, linear function
of x, x in m dimensions.
OK.
So one little math
question which I think
helps to understand,
to like to swallow
the idea of a chain, of the
kind of chain we have here,
of linear followed by ReLU.
So here's my question.
This is the question
I'm going to ask.
And by the way, back
propagation is certainly
going to come Wednesday
rather than today.
That's a major topic in itself.
So let me keep going
with this function.
Could you get any function
whatsoever this way?
Well, no, you only get
continuous, piecewise,
linear functions.
It's an interesting case.
Let me just ask you.
One of the exercises
says, if I took
two continuous, piecewise,
linear functions--
the next 20 minutes
are an attempt
to give us a picture of
the graph of a piecewise,
linear function in say a
function of two variables.
So I have m equal to 2,
and I draw its graph.
OK, help me to draw this graph.
So this would be a
graph of F of x1, x2,
and it's going to be continuous
and piecewise linear.
So what does its
graph look like?
That's the question.
What's the graph of a piecewise,
linear function looks like?
Well, it's got flat pieces
in between the change from--
I do say piecewise, that means
it's got different pieces.
But within a piece, it's linear,
and the pieces with each other,
because it's continuous.
So I visualize, well,
it's like origami.
This is the theory
of origami almost.
So right, origami,
you take a flat thing,
and you fold it
along straight folds.
So what's different
from origami?
Maybe not much.
Well, maybe origami allows
more than we allow here,
or origami would allow you
to fold it up and over.
So origami would give
you a multi-valued thing,
because it's got a top and
a bottom and other folds.
This is just going out to
infinity in flat pieces,
and the question will
be, how many pieces?
So let me ask you that question.
How many pieces do I have?
Do you see what I
mean by a piece?
So I'm thinking of a graph
that has these flat pieces,
and they're connected
along straight edges.
And those straight edges
come from the ReLU operation.
Well, that's got two pieces.
Actually, we could do it 1D.
In 1D, we could count the
number of pieces pretty easily.
So what would be a
piecewise linear?
Let me put it over here on
the side and erase it soon.
OK.
So here's m equal 1, a
continuous, piecewise, linear
F. I'll just draw its graph.
So OK, so it's got
straight pieces,
straight pieces like so.
Yeah, you've got the idea.
It's a broken line type.
Sometimes, people
say broken line,
but I'm never sure that's
a good description of this.
Piecewise, linear,
continuous, so it's continuous
because the pieces meet,
and it's piecewise,
linear, obviously.
OK, so that's the
kind of picture
I have for a function
of one variable.
Now, my question is--
as an aid to try to visualize
this function in 2D--
is to see if we can
count the pieces,
see if we can count the pieces.
Yes.
So that's in the notes.
I found it in a paper by
five authors for a meeting.
So actually, the whole
world of neural nets,
it's the conferences
every couple of years
that everybody prepares for,
submits more than one paper.
So it's kind of a piecewise,
linear conference,
and those are the
big conferences.
OK.
So this is the back
propagation section,
and I want to look at the--
OK.
So this is a paper by
Kleinberg and four others.
Kleinberg, he's a computer
science guy at Cornell.
He was a PhD from
here in math, and he's
a very cool and
significant person,
not so much on neural networks
as just this whole part
of computer science.
Right.
So anyway, they and
other people too
have asked this same problem.
Suppose I'm in two variables.
So what are you imagining
now for the surface,
the graph of F of x and y?
It has these lines,
fold lines, right?
I'm thinking it has fold lines.
So I can start with a
complete plane, and I fold it
along one line.
So now, it's like ReLU.
It's one half plane there going
into a different half plane
there.
Everybody with it?
And now, I take that
function, that surface
which just has two parts,
and I put in another fold.
OK, how many parts
have I got now?
I think four, am I right?
Four parts, yes, because this
will be different from this,
because it was folded
along that line.
So these will be four
different pieces.
They have the same value
at the center there,
and they match along the lines.
So the number of flat
pieces is four for this.
So that's with two folds, and
now I just want to ask you,
with m folds how many
pieces are there?
Can I get up to three folds?
So I'm going to look
for the number of folds.
So let me just use
a notation, maybe r.
r is the number of flat pieces,
and m is the dimension of x.
In my picture, it's two, and
N is the number of folds.
So let me say it again.
I'm taking a plane.
I'll fold that plane--
because the dimension was two--
I'll fold it N times.
How many pieces?
How many flat pieces?
This would be a central
step in understanding
how close the function--
what freedom you have in
the function F. For example,
can you approximate
any continuous function
by one of these functions
F by taking enough folds?
Seems like the answer should
be yes, and it is yes.
For pure math,
that's one question.
Is this class of
functions universal?
So the universality
theorem would
be to say that any function--
sine x, whatever--
could be approximated
as close as you like by one of
these guys with enough folds.
And over here, we're kind
of making it more numerical.
We're going to count
the number of pieces
just to see how
quickly do they grow.
So what happens here?
So I have four folds.
Right now, I have N equal 2.
m is 2 here in this picture.
And I'm trying to draw this
surface, in here I've put in 2.
Did I take N?
Yeah, two folds, and now I'm
going to go up to three folds.
OK.
So let me fold it
along that line.
How many pieces of I got now?
Let's see, can I
count those pieces?
Is it seven?
So what is a formula?
What if I do another fold?
Yeah, let's pretend
we do another fold.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: Uh, yeah.
Well, maybe that's
going to be it.
It's a kind of nice
question, because it asks
you to visualize this thing.
OK.
So what happened?
How many of those
lines will be--
if I put in a fourth line--
how many?
Yeah, how many new
folds do I create?
That's kind of the
question, and I'm
assuming that
fourth line doesn't
go through any of these points.
It's sort of in
general position.
So I put it in a fourth line,
da-da-da-da, there it is.
OK, so what happened here?
How many new ones did it create?
Let me make that one
green, because I'm
distinguishing
that's the guy that's
added after the original.
We had seven.
We had seven pieces,
and now we've got more.
Was it seven?
It was, wasn't it?
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, but now how many
pieces have I got?
Or how many pieces did
this new line create?
We want to build it
up, use a recursion.
How many pieces did this new--
well, this new line created
one new piece there.
Right?
One new piece there,
one new piece there,
one new piece there, so
there are four new pieces.
OK.
Yes, so there's
some formula that's
going to tell us that, and now
what would the next one create?
Well, now I have one,
two, three, four lines.
So now, I'm going to put
through a fifth line,
and that will create a
whole bunch of pieces.
I'm losing the thread of this
argument, but you're onto it.
Right?
Yeah, so any suggestions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think you add
essentially the number of lines
that you have each time
you add a line at most.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
Yes.
That's right.
So there is a recursion
formula that I want to know,
and I learned it from
Kleinberg's paper.
And then we have
an addition to do,
so the recursion will tell
me how much it goes up
with each new function,
and then we have to add.
OK.
So the recursion formula,
let me write that down.
So this is r of N and m that
I'd like to find a formula for.
It's the number of flat pieces
with an m dimensional surface--
well, we're taking m to be 2--
and N folds.
So N equal 1, 2, 3.
Let's write down
the numbers we know.
With one fold, how many pieces?
Two, good, so far so good.
With one fold, there
were two pieces.
So this is the count r, and
then with two folds, how many?
Oh, we've gone past that point.
So can we get back
to just those two?
Was it four?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GILBERT STRANG: OK, thanks.
Now, when I put in that third
fold, how many did I have
without the green line yet?
Seven, was it seven?
And when the fourth one went in,
that green one, how many have I
got in this picture?
So the question is how many
new ones did I create, I guess.
So that line got chopped
into that piece, that piece,
that piece, that piece, four
pieces for the new line.
Four pieces for the new line,
and then each of those pieces
like added a flat bit.
Because that piece
from here to here
separated these two
which were previously
just one piece, one flat piece.
I folded on that line.
I folded on this.
I folded there.
I think it went up by 4 to 11.
So now, we just have
to guess a formula that
matches those numbers, and
then of course, we really
should guess it for
any m and any N.
And I'll write down the
formula that they found.
It involves binomial numbers.
Everything in the world
involves binomial numbers,
because they satisfy every
identity you could think of.
So here's their formula.
r with N folds, and
we're in m dimensions.
So we've really in our
thinking had m equal to 2,
but we should grow up and
get m to be five dimensional.
So we have a five dimensional--
let's not think about that.
OK.
So it turns out it's
binomial numbers--
N 0, N 1, up to N m.
So for m equals 2, which is
my picture, it's N 0 plus N 1
plus N 2, and what are these?
What does that N 2
mean, for example?
That's a binomial number.
I don't know if you're
keen on binomial numbers.
Some people, their whole lives
go into binomial numbers.
So it's something like--
is it N factorial divided
by N minus 2 factorial and 2
factorial?
I think that's what
that number means.
That's the binomial number.
So at this point, I'm hoping to
get the answer seven, I think.
I'm in m equal to--
I've gone up to 2.
Yeah, so I think I've obviously
allowed for three cuts,
and the r, when we
had just three, was 7.
So this is now I'm
taking N to be 3,
and I'm hoping for answer is 7.
So I add these three things.
So what is 3, the
binomial number 3 with 2?
I've forgotten how to say that.
I'm ashamed to admit.
3 choose 2, thanks.
I knew there was a good way.
So what is 3 choose 2?
Well, put in 3, and 2
is in there already,
so that'd be 6 over 1 times 2.
This would be 3.
Would that be 3?
And what is 3 choose 1?
AUDIENCE: 3.
GILBERT STRANG: How
do you know that?
You're probably right.
3, I think, yeah.
Oh yeah, probably a theorem
that if these add 3.
Yeah, so I'm doing
N equals 3 here.
OK.
So yeah, I agree.
That's 3, and what about N to 0?
That you have to live
with 0 factorial,
but 0 factorial
is by no means 0.
So what is 0 factorial?
1, yeah.
I remember when I was
an undergraduate having
a bet on that.
I won, but he didn't pay off.
Yeah, so it's 3.
This is 3 factorial over 3
factorial times 0 factorial.
So it's 6 over 6 times 1.
So it's 1.
Yeah, 1 and 3 and 3 make 7.
So that proves the formula.
Well, it doesn't quite
prove the formula,
but the way to prove
it is by an induction.
If you like this stuff,
the recursion that you use
induction on.
Which is just what we did
now, what we did here.
Here comes in a number
4, and it cuts through,
and then we just counted
the 4 pieces there.
So yeah, so let me just tell
you what the r then and m.
The number we're looking
for is the number
that we had with one less cut.
So that's the previous
count of flat pieces
plus the number that was here
was 4, the number of pieces
that cut that.
And that's r of N
minus 1, m minus 1.
Yeah, and I won't go further.
Time's up, but that
rule for recursion
is proved in the section
7.1 taken from the paper
by Kleinberg and others.
Yeah.
So OK, I think this is--
I don't know what you feel.
For me, this like gave
me a better feeling
that I was understanding what
kind of functions we had here.
And so then the question is--
with this family
of functions, we
want to choose the A's and
the weights, the A's and b's,
to match the training data.
So that we have a problem in
minimizing the total loss,
and we have a gradient
descent problem.
So we have to find the gradient,
so that Wednesday's job.
Wednesday's job is to
find the gradient of F,
and that's back propagation.
Good.
Thank you very much.
7.1 is done.